let's cross over to former u.s army
green beret and afghan war veteran
lieutenant colonel scott mann who joins
me now you've been
in the u.s army you've been to
afghanistan many times a sad day as
there have been
u.s casualties potentially unconfirmed
reports of u.s casualties uh in this
attack
yeah the the the attack was horrific and
our thoughts and prayers go out to
um our afghan families and um any
families of our of our warriors
and diplomats who are who who may have
been injured or killed doing this
amazing mission and here's what i want
to say is whatever uh leaders political
leaders are saying about most of our
partners got out that is an absolute
falsehood
i'm part of an informal group known as
task force pineapple retired green
berets navy seals and diplomats who for
the last seven days with no sleep have
been doing in a private organization
what our government wouldn't do and i
have firsthand information that there
are thousands of siv holders of other
people who we made a commitment to get
out
military partners in the special
operations community of the afghans
that were that have not made it out and
our task force moved out 500 last night
through holes in the wall and
sewage-filled canals talking them
through uh on our cell phones uh with
messages like this i have one adult six
kids that abbey gate with no comms uh
the the the six-year-old died if anyone
can help them get out it would be huge
and then we coordinate with these heroes
on the inside who basically defied
orders wade into the canal and pull them
through this went on all night long it's
been going on for five days and we're
nowhere near where we need to be we need
our governments to push out to reinforce
and let's honor our commitment and let's
get our american citizens our british
citizens and these at-risk afghans out
of there uh or i think it's gonna haunt
us with these kinds of attacks at on the
home front for a very long time
you clearly feel and sound let down by
president biden's decision-making and
approach to this effort um
you've been an advisor to the u.s army
on afghanistan what do you think they
should be doing now
well for one thing we should not be
letting the taliban call the tune on how
we evacuate our citizens as nato that's
that's patently ridiculous um we should
push out the perimeter i believe you
know citizens in the uk and the us
should be calling their parliamentarians
their congressmen and demanding
that that we stand up and and and
perform the way we're supposed to
perform the way the world expects us to
perform this is genocide played out in
real time uh on on the 24-hour news
cycle everyone is seeing it and it's a
it's a fraction of what's coming it's a
fraction um and and we have an
opportunity now to shift momentum and do
the right thing and right now i'm
telling you there are there are informal
groups who are actively working to get
our people out of there and our afghan
partners we're doing it with cell phones
and relationships and we're not done
even with if the gates close we're going
to move them over land we're not done
and i hope that the western world will
not turn its eye on afghanistan again
because um we just can't do that from a
moral level
this
sounds like it
might not be according to all the
analysts we've been speaking to since
this attack it might not be the only one
that's to come over the next few days
things could get worse do you believe
the troops should stay longer beyond the
august 31st deadline
i've always
held that belief i'm a green beret and
and our specialty is training indigenous
uh people and host nation partners and
you know everybody there's this
narrative going around that the afghans
didn't fight the afghan commandos fought
until the last bullet and they were
abandoned by their president their
senior officers who were bribed and our
political administrations uh in the west
particularly mine and it doesn't it
pains me to say that but you know at
this point uh with what we're having to
do to cover down to to do the right
thing and sure no one's left behind i
don't care because that's what happened
and we have the capacity to stay
and build capacity with the afghan
people it doesn't have to be a huge
footprint and we can continue to target
these cells we got hit on 911 because we
had no network on the ground we've had
20 years there to build this network and
we're using it right now to evacuate 500
people last night and we're getting
ready to walk away from it again
how do you think that's going to play
out in the west when we do that
surely president biden can't do a u-turn
now and change his mind and stay
why not i mean
we're there we have that we have the
horsepower to at least push out the
perimeter and establish a presence that
would allow us in an organized fashion
to open these gates and and withdraw at
least our afghan partners and allies who
are at extreme risk
i think the cost of not doing that on a
moral level will haunt us for the rest
of our days the graveyard of empires
will follow us home